what brought you back to the island I
need you ow
there is a man here named Adrian cheese
he's holding my friends and my family
hostage we won't make it like old times
the way Oliver just is so yes what makes
you think even knows where we are he get
a weapon I don't I trusted more than you
didn t kill your mother
[Music]
you know what I'm up against here help
me take the out chase you walk my past
is coming back to haunt me since we were
cool and flame with you hello Oliver if
you want to get your son back you know
what you have to talk I have no interest
since being a fair fight
we got some new destro footage let's
break this down and we learn what the
deal is they free Oliver's friends and
they walk that includes Captain
Boomerang and Deathstroke so I am so
hoping that Slade just walks off the
island it just causes all kinds of
trouble that they can surface in future
seasons there's a flash ring giveaway
going on right now all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber leave a comment
on this video in a lot of you have asked
flash related questions because they
were at Argus but then when we got to
the arrow episode Diggle said that his
wife Lila was in Chicago visiting family
so apparently they weren't near this
Argus facility where the Suicide Squad
was being kept underground next to that
alien power source in for those of you
wondering about the underground bunker
on the island obviously Slade's been in
there this whole time and you finally
get a shot of another hallway with the
guards that Oliver takes down that's
important too but you learn how slay
gets fed that's one of the biggest
questions that I've gotten the last
couple seasons how does Slade eat that
somebody come down there and feed him
because you only get the shot of Oliver
climbing up the ladder so it makes it
seem like it's the prison in the ladder
and that's it but it's actually like
this bigger underground facility but I
can't remember which episode it was but
there was a reference to another person
I think it was when he went back in they
thought Slade during season 3 when he
was with Thea and there was a reference
to another cellmate that Slade had down
there and it was supposed to be Captain
Boomerang from after the season 3
crossover the episode 8 brave in the
bold when they took him down but that
almost reminds me they actually started
talking about the new four-way crossover
that's coming I'll talk about that at
the end of the video just because this
is so much bigger right now but you get
some more shots of Deathstroke in action
so it looks like you know everybody has
their role on the team team arrow vs.
team prometheus Oh Oliver is going to be
the one to fight prometheus you have
canary on canary action I'm going to
assume that Thea is going to be fighting
Artemis Merlyn might be fighting Talia's
people with Deathstroke because you just
see Deathstroke just tearing through all
these people like tissue paper so I
loved the pitch that they must have
given the new Bennet when they were like
hey we want you to come back and play
with us for the finale you were going to
slay a ton of people even though Oliver
hero of the show is going to get to dig
victory over prometheus because he's
actually a really cool dude in real life
he goes to a lot of conventions so odds
are pretty good that you'll bump into
him somewhere if you go to conventions
you could probably get him to sign some
Deathstroke gear but really like the
whole point of this new trailer is just
to fill the story out a little bit and
to let you know the Captain Boomerang is
there I assume they just didn't finish
editing the longer versions of trailer
till just today but I think of all the
matchups that I'm looking forward to
most
aside from Deathstroke I mean everybody
is pumped about Deathstroke he is
featured prominently in all their
marketing I mean just look at him here
you just can't wait to see him put that
mask on and just pull the sword out and
go to it but I'm really looking forward
to Stephen Amell fighting Joss Segarra
he's the person who's been playing
Prometheus this whole season he's been
an excellent villain I hope that they do
not kill him off now this is big thing
going on in the flash TV show where it
seems like no matter what Barry does he
can't get rid of Sava tar because like a
future version of him just creates
another time remnant that becomes
another Savitt R so the minute you
defeats avatar poof there's another one
that just comes back along the timeline
he's almost like a living paradox now
like the reverse-flash but didn't easing
that this ultimate showdown is not going
to end in this like the hero punching
the crap out of the bill and there's
going to be some twist some other way to
solve the problem in what prometheus
wants is for oliver to kill him to prove
that he's been right this whole time so
all that oliver has to do is defeat
prometheus without killing him which
means that he might take Slade's spot in
that underground bunker only to show up
in a future season again - so let me
know in the comments how do you guys
think the Prometheus storyline is going
to end do you think he's going to wind
up on ice in one of those bunkers or in
an Argos prison or do you think he's
going to escape and fly off into the
wind to cause more trouble in future
seasons so Marc Guggenheim has already
said that the season 6 villain is called
covenant he didn't say the Covenant he
just said covenant so what I'll do is
when we get a little bit closer I'll do
a season 6 video the same is true of
season 4 of the flash we know a little
bit more about season 4 the flash then
we know about season 6 of arrow just
because the flash TV show tends to be
more comic-book specific so if you've
read comics you have a better chance of
predicting what's going on on the flash
the u-2 on
Eero but they tend to do a good job of
keeping around the biggest most
important fan favorite characters they
killed Katie Cassidy off the show then
brought her right back
that is your barometer for bringing back
fan favorite characters they even
brought shadow back as a mystery twin in
the season 3 flashbacks Beryl Minh is
the only person who says that his
character is not coming back next season
he didn't say he's never coming back but
he seems like one of those characters
that's always game to play so on the
potential list of deaths in the finale
he's pretty high up the list but he'll
always come back to the show in
flashbacks they even did all that Tommy
stuff this season even though Colin
Donald didn't have time to come on the
show where's your son oh he's a doctor
now in Chicago making the joke about how
the fact that Colin Donnell in real life
is on a show called Chicago Hope playing
a doctor so they haven't released an
extended trailer for the flash panella
yet that might happen in the next day or
two
whenever it drops I'll do another video
for it they always include a bunch of
extra footage but they did drop a whole
bunch of pictures like the one of
Prometheus here inside STAR Labs looking
like he's really upset to have to have
to work with Barry over some problem so
that is a big wrinkle for the flash
finale I'll be talking about that this
weekend it'll be a lot of fun that big
news about the four night crossover
that's happening this next season is
that it might actually come a couple
weeks earlier than it normally does they
just said November but usually because
it's episode 8 of arrow and flash it's a
little bit later in November just
because episode 9 is in December and
that's the mid-season finale so they
might end up doing it around episode 7
maybe even episode 6 just don't be
surprised at the time to dig for night
crossover around Thanksgiving weekend so
just like everybody's sitting around the
TV they usually drop a lot of Netflix
series around then too because people
are on vacation they're watching more
stuff and there's more advertising
dollars to get done so we'll see how
that goes but they did say that Black
Lightning has no plans to join that four
night crossover so if you guys didn't
know the injustice game dropped this
week hopefully you've had a chance to
play it I've already posted a review
video there's an injustice giveaway
going on in that too that is on top of
the flash ring giveaway that's going on
right now so be sure and check that
video out you can click here for that
and you can click here for brand new
play and and you can click here to learn
how
Tom Hardy is the new venom in the
spider-verse
he's going to play venom this is crazy
thank you so much for watching let's
high five see you guys tonight